now I think most of you have realized
and just alluded to it just now the
tangents are going to be involved where
I attention to get me involved the monk
I'm if you think about measuring an
angle from the origin okay you're like
yeah of course you can get a smaller
argument than pilot for you just sort of
took your lying down right and somewhat
you took your lying down and up can you
see here this like here the one that
goes all the way through the deadline
what's that called by the way has a name
that's the nest that's a secret right at
some point when you start tilting down
your secret stops being a secret and it
becomes a tangent right so what you're
going to get is something like that yeah
that was actually very recently on the
spot okay so there's one of the tangents
see like that looks like the smaller
angle obviously you got a further you
know the circle anymore and
correspondingly there's going to be a
tangent that gives you the biggest thing
it will be something like that okay so
when you look at this you're like well
now the question becomes how do i find
the arguments here all right so here's
what I'm going to do and this is why the
constructions over here a clouding my
diagram which lab made a whole new one
think about what you know about the
arguments in this circle okay so for
example I know what the argument is too
bad guy of their right this is going to
be pilot for I already have that in my
mind if this angle here I've this item
is pilot for and the argument I'm really
after is that one then if I can find the
difference between those two like this
guy then this will just be PI on for
take away that do you agree with that so
many times so how do I go about finding
this angle okay well angles if I can
have triangles around that'll be really
useful the question what triangles will
help me on here I took advantage of the
radius do you remember that I used it to
get back and forth between these points
okay I can do the same thing
I can do the same few key the triangle
I'm going to form is this guy okay
because remember what kind of life is
this again it's a tangent so therefore
if I draw away from the center to my
tangent it's going to be yeah that's
going to be so useful isn't it okay
that's what we feel in here right it's
the radius which is to this line I've
drawn to all the way the origin to form
this triangle I already know it's 02 to
32 what was the angle is trying to find
it it's this one is this one of the
corner right well what is this from this
point of view that's opposite on
hypotenuse so sine of this angle is this
on this on Reuters are going to cancel
that's just one on to one or two so how
many degrees that it's 30 degrees so
that's PI 06 yeah you see what I've done
okay now you already know that this is
PI on for so the little angle you're
after is pile informe de Guerre play on
65 14 what is that you sure that you
high on 12 or 12 are you happy with that
you saw how i got it right the numbers
not that one so now I did the smallest
that I did can be okay that was the hard
part my diagrams not great because of my
circle looking fantastic but to find the
angle over to the farthest argument I'm
just going to rinse and repeat right
like again I can form the same triangle
because my my circles a bit squash it
doesn't look like as much of a right
angle as it is but you know its
attention and you know it's a radius
right so in fact it's the same triangle
is congruent right so what's this angle
still pansies so now the angle I'm after
is going to be not pylon for takeaway
plan zigs it's going to be plan for plus
pile of 6
this angle here great which last I
checked if I have my range correct this
is our last I checked that's going to be
5 PI over 12 we can check the numbers
you can see what I do that's a great
question in terms of like whenever it's
like or what do I what do I have to do
okay the first thing you should know is
like as mathematicians um hello do i do
I have to prove that like a quarter take
away a sixth is a 12th like hmm let me
just like you wouldn't believe the kinds
of discussions that have been had about
like he is that really true like is one
plus one really equal to I know that
sounds like the punchline to a joke but
it's a serious question right now the
answer that question is well you have a
look at like what are you trying to
prove where are you at mathematically
okay and this is clearly not a question
about simplifying fractions or proving
the triangles are congruent in fact
extension to students they have this
phrase that they've really really love
it's called by inspection it's basically
a way of saying hey there's this thing
in this diagram it's kind of obvious I
don't really need to prove it it's not
really the point of this question like
congruence or like similarity which is
not at all the focus of the extension to
course so the short answer your question
is no the way I know that the answer is
no is because I look at this question
and like it's not interested at all in
that and it's not like a seven mark
question make sure you prove that it's
gone go if they wanted to give you a
hand what they would do is pose this
question like this is really like five
questions in one is it not I think of
the number of Stephanie and to throw
through here so exam right is like the
reason why we give you multipop
questions is we trying to help you out
we're trying to nudge you in a
particular direction of claw a might be
proved those triangles of congo if we're
trying to give you two free marks
basically okay all right how do with
that does it make sense so there are my
two ranges okay